>> Ashley: BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
PLANNING ROLL OUT NIE SYSTEM
AIMED AT SPEEDING UP ASYLUM.
>> Todd: CAN GRANT PROTECTION TO
MIGRANTS, SOMETHING ONLY
IMMIGRATION JUDGES USED TO BE
ABLE TO DO BEFORE THIS RULE.
THE RULE SAYS OFFICERS CANNOT
DENY PROTECTION MIGRANTS
REJECTED MUST FACE A JUDGE AND
GIVES MIGRANTS THE RIGHT TO
APPEAL A JUDGE'S VERDICT.
>> Ashley: JONATHAN FAHEY JOINS
US.
DO YOU THINK THIS NEW SYSTEM
WILL HELP OR HURT BECAUSE TEXAS
ATTORNEY GENERAL PAXTON FILED
FOR PRELIMINARY INJUNCTION IN
COURT SAYING THIS WILL
ACCELERATE THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION.
I THINK IT WILL HELP AND HELP
ILLEGAL ALIENS GET INTO THE
COUNTRY AND STAY IN THE COUNTRY
AND ENCOURAGE MORE.
IN TERMS OF HELPING, IT WILL
HELP IN THAT RESPECT.
THIS IS LIKE EVERYTHING THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE ON
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, EITHER
DESIGNED TO INCREASE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION OR TO PRETEND LIKE
THEY ARE DOING SOMETHING ABOUT
THE PROBLEM WHEN THEY ARE NOT.
THIS WILL ACTUALLY DO BOTH.
>> Todd: JONATHAN, HOW IS THIS
LEGAL?
WHY DOES THIS ADMINISTRATION
THINK HE CAN REMOVE JURISDICTION
FROM A COURT AND GIVE IT TO A
BUREAUCRAT?
>> YEAH, THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION BECAUSE WHAT ARE THEY
DOING HERE?
THEY'RE BASICALLY DELEGAING
JUDICIAL ROLE, ALTHOUGH THESE
ARE NOT ARTICLE THREE JUDGES,
DELEGATING TO EMPLOYEES OF U.S.
CIS, THAT IS TRAINED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY ARE GOING TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR PEOPLE TO BE GRANTED ASYLUM
AND THEN ONCE THEY ARE GRANTED
ASYLUM, THEY'RE HERE PERMANENTLY
WITH LEGAL STATUS, BUT PEOPLE
NOT GRANTED ASILEUM WILL BE
GRANTED ASYLUM, THEY WON'T BE
REMOVED UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES
WHATSOEVER.
THIS ADMINISTRATION TALKS ABOUT
DEPORTATION PROCEEDINGS, BUT
THEY ARE NOT BE DEPORTED.
LIST OF PEOPLE NOT DEPORTED IS
1.5 MILLION, THEY WILL BE PUT ON
THAT PILE AND AT THE RATE OF
DEPORTING 59,000 A YEAR, WE'RE
LOOKING AT 25 YEARS TO GET TO
PEOPLE ORDERED DEPORTED
EVENTUALLY.
>> Ashley: WHAT IS THE DIFFERENT
IN QUALIFICATION WITH ASYLUM
OFFICERS VERSUS ASYLUM JUDGES
AND HOW CAN THAT BE MUDDY WITH
INFORMATION GIVEN OUT?
>> I THINK SOME THINGS THAT ARE
DANGEROUS IS IF IT IS ASYLUM
OFFICERS THAT ARE TRAINED, THERE
IS NO REVIEW OF WHAT THEY DO, IF
THEY ARE GRANTED ASYLUM TO
PEOPLE THAT DON'T DESERVE
ASYLUM, NO WAY TO REVIEW THAT,
NO JUDGE TRAINED ON THIS.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THERE IS
ANNAD VERSE
ARIAL PR
THERE.
THEY WILL BE GRANTED ASYLUM AND
IT SHOULD BE A THOROUGH PROCESS.
ASYLUM IS NOT COMING TO THIS
COUNTRY SAYING YOU PREFER TO
LIVE HERE THAN WHERE YOU
CURRENTLY LIVE BECAUSE YOU WILL
BE MORE PROSPEROUS HERE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SUPPOSEDLY
FLEEING PERSECUTION AND MASSIVE
MIGRATION PATTERNS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED ARE NOT PEOPLE FLEEING
PERSECUTION.
THEY ARE PEOPLE FLEEING TO THE
UNITED STATES BECAUSE THEY HAVE
JOE BIDEN AS PRESIDENT AND HE
WILL GIVE THEM EVERY RIGHT,
PRIVILEGE AND BENEFIT THAT
AMERICAN CITIZENS RECEIVE.
>> Todd: ASYLUM IS TOUGH
STANDARD TO REACH, 31,000
GRANTED ASYLUM IN 2021.
UNDER THIS NEW APPROACH, HOW
HIGH THAL NUMBER GO WHEN YOU
HAVE LOOK AT THE SCREEN RIGHT
NOW, A MILLION PEOPLE
ENCOUNTERED AT THE BORDER IN
FISCAL 2022 SO FAR?
>> YOU FIGURE THE PURPOSE OF
THIS IS TO ONE, ENCOURAGE MORE
PEOPLE TO COME, THEY WILL KNOW
IT IS GOING TO BE EASIER.
MY GUESS, IT WILL BE LOWER THAN
THE 90% NUMBER, THE FLOOD GATES
ARE WIDER OPEN AND ALSO PEOPLE
WILL BE GRANTED ASYLUM QUICKLY
AND IF NOT GRANTED QUICKLY, PUT
IN THE SAME OLD PROCESS.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE STAYING IN
THIS COUNTRY, TOO.
MY GUESS, FAR LOWER THAN THE
NORMAL STANDARD AND THE
ADMINISTRATION NOW WILL CONTROL
WHAT THAT NUMBER IS BECAUSE THEY
CAN TRAIN PEOPLE TO LET IN AS
MANY PEOPLE AS THEY WANT, LOOSEN
STANDARDS AS MUCH AS THEY WANT.
THIS HAS BEEN A POLITICAL MOVE
AND THEY WANT AS MANY ILLEGAL
ALIENS TO COME IN AS POSSIBLE
AND WILL DO EVERYTHING THEY CAN
TO DO IT.
THIS IS TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE
THEY ARE PROTECTING IN THE
MIDTERM.
OPEN BORDERS AND AMNESTY.
>> Ashley: FORMER I